قالت هيئه الدفاع عن السجناء السياسيين في
تونس ان دخول رموز من المعارضه في اضراب
عن الطعام جاء احتجاجا على ما وصفتها
بفضيحه قضائيه يقودها قاضي التحقيق عبر
ملفات مرفقه ضد معارضي الرئيس قيس سعيد
ياتي ذلك بعد دخول رئيس حركه النهضه راشد
الغنوشي في اضراب عن الطعام تضامنا مع
خطوه المماثله لعضو جبهه الخلاص جوهر بن
مبارك
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما مدى وجاهه وصف هيئه
الدفاع عن السجناء السياسيين في تونس
تعامل قاض التحقيق مع ملفاتهم بالفضيحه
القضائيه وما دلالات ذلك فيما يتعلق بما
ال اليه المشهد في تونس سياسيا وحقوقيا اي
فاعليه لخطوه الاضراب عن الطعام في في
تحريك ملف المعتقلين السياسيين في تونس
وهل من شانها ان تدفع المجتمع المحلي
والحقوقي العالمي للتدخل والضغط لدعمهم
وانصاف الى اين تتجه الازمه في تونس
بالنظر لتعاطي السلطات مع ملف المعتقلين
السياسيين والمطالبات في الداخل والخارج
باطلاق سراحهم والبدء في حوار يخرج البلاد
من ازمتها السياسيه والاقتصاديه
الخانقه
[موسيقى]
في سياق المواجهه بين السلطات التونسيه
ومعارضي الرئيس قيس سعيد دشنت شخصيات
معتقله بارزه ما وصفت بمعركه الامعاء
الخاويه في مواجهه تعامل السلطه مع
المعتقلين السياسيين هيئه الدفاع عن اولئك
المعتقلين تحدثت عن فضيحه قضائيه قائله ان
قاضي التحقيق في القطب القضائي المختص في
قضايا الارهاب يقودها ضد معارضي الرئيس
قيس سعيد تشير الهيئه بذلك الى ما تعتبرها
خروق قضائيه صارخه وغير مسبوقه في التعاطي
مع ملفات تتضمن تهما لمعارضين بالتامر على
امن الدوله والتخابر مع دبلوماسيين غربيين
والفساد المالي ودرجت الهيئه على التاكيد
على ان تلك الملفات قائمه على محتوى فارغ
لا يستند الى ادنى حجه او دليل فضلا عن
محجوزات تدين المعتقلين ورغم ذلك يتم دون
وجه قانوني رفض مطالب الافراج عنهم وفيما
تمر تونس بازمه سياسيه واخرى اقتصاديه
خانقه يتمسك الرئيس قيس سعيد بكونه انما
يسعى لتصحيح اهداف الثوره ومحاربه الفساد
نافيا ان يكون قد هيمن على كل السلطات
ووظف القضاء لقمع معارضيه وفق ما يتهمه به
اولئك
[موسيقى]
المعارضون
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من مدينه رفراف
في محافظه بنزرت في تونس سمير ديلو عضو
اللجنه التنفيذيه لجبهه الخلاص الوطني
وعضو هيئه الدفاع عن
المعتقلين من تونس الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
محمد دويب ومن باريس فرانسوا دوش رئيس
جمعيه عداله وحقوق بلا حدود سيد ديلو ابدا
بك اهلا وسهلا
لماذا يعتبر ما حدث ما حدث يعتبر فضيحه
قضائيه الجواب
بسيط مجموعه من القاده السياسيين يتم
اعتقالهم منذ اكثر من سبعه اشهر وفي
الاثناء تمر سته اشهر الاولى ثم يمدد
ايقافهم دون اي مبرر واقعي ولا قانوني ولا
اجرائي توجه لهم تهمه التامر للاعتداء على
هيئه الدوله بدون اي محجوز ولا ادله ولا
شهادات ولا قرائن وتهمه التخابر مع
دبلوماسيين اجانب ولكن في الاثناء يتم
تبرئه هؤلاء الدبلوماسيين الاجانب بينما
يبقى منوب واصدقائنا معتقلين بتهمه
التخابر وكلما قدمنا مطلبا للافراج الا
ووجهنا بعباره غريبه تطلب النيابه
العموميه رفض مطلب الافراج نظرا لخطوره
تهم المواجهه لل المناوبين وخاصه التخابر
مع الدبلوماسيين الاجانب هذا اضطرنا الى
ان نقدم اليوم مطلب للسيد قاضي التحقيق
للاستماع لسته من الدبلوماسيين الاجانب
حتى نتبين مدى صحه تهمه التخابر المنسوبه
لمنو بنا علما بانه من نافه القول ان
التخابر هو تماما كزواج لا يكون بطرف واحد
طبعا هناك من يرى ان ان هؤلاء يحاكمون
موجب قوانين اعتمدت اصلا في العشريه
السابقه اثناء حكم النهضه وحلفائها
وبالتالي يعني لماذا الاعتراض على هذه
القوانين الان وما جدوى ان ان يرد عليها
باضراب عن
الطعام كانت القوانين موجوده ولكن القاده
السياسيين المعارضين كانوا في اي في
التلفزات والاذاعات ينقدون كما يشاؤون
ويعارضون كما يشاؤون بينما قطب مكافحه
الارهاب كان موجها للذين رفعوا السلاح ضد
الدوله والذين اغتالوا الامنيين
والعسكريين اما الان فيكاد قطب مكافحه
الارهاب يصبح متخصصا في محاكمه القاده
السياسيين والمعارضين السياسيين وحتى
المدونين الذين تعتبر مجرد تدوينه ناقده
للسلطه موجبا الاحاله بموجب قانون الارهاب
ومجرد التعريض برئيس الجمهوريه موجبا حاله
بتهمه اتيان امر موحش تجاه رئيس
الجمهوريه حسنا سيد فرانسوا دروش كيف
تواكب المنظمات الحقوقيه الدوليه
والاوروبيه تحديدا ما يحدث في تونس بين
روايتين روايه كالتي استمعنا اليها من
السيد سمير ديلو وروايه اخرى تقول انه لا
لا ظلم او قمع في هذا الامر هناك من ارتكب
مخالفات قانونيه ويحاكم بموجب
القانون
سعدتم مساء انتم ومشاهد وضيوفكم اولا ان
العالم برمته عالم الحر وكل المنظمات
الدوليه تشعر بدهشه لما يحصل في تونس
اليوم ف خاصه بعد اخر
اعلان للتغييرات الكبيره اللي قام بها
الرئيس قيس سعيد لم تعدت تونس يصغى اليها
او يسمعها العالم الحر او العالم
الديمقراطي اليوم نجد ان القانون والحريات
مهدده بالخطر في تونس هناك مطارده للاجانب
هناك مطارده للافارقه وهناك هذه هذا الهوس
مساله الهجره بما يجعل يجعل اوروبا عمياء
ازاء ما يحصل في ضد انتهاكات حقوق الانسان
في تونس اليوم نستطيع
القول معارضون
السياسيين اليوم معتقلون في السجون وحتى
لو ان النظام يحاول ان يقول انهم
مجرمون ولكنهم في الواقع العالم يعرف انهم
هؤلاء رجال سياسه وهم في السجن بسبب بسيط
لانهم لانه لعدم وجود احترام ل حطيه
الكلام والتعبير في
تونس النظام الحالي في تونس ليس لديه الا
فكره واحده في راسه الا وهي انتخابات 2024
والنظام مقتنع بانه لابد من تخلص كل
الشخصيات السياسيه الذين يحملون قيمه وق
قوه حقيقيه ويفرضون تركهم في السجون اليوم
ومعاملتهم
كخون يخضعون القانون الجزائي
وبالتالي نجد ان غنوشي وغيره وكل الرجال
السياسيين الذين
معه وجود هذا يشكل خجلا خج على لتونس
والعالم كله لقبولهم بما يجري اليوم ولكن
مع الاسف هناك ارباك او عدم
فهم قد يكون
طوعي بين ما هو الدوله وما هو الرئيس ودون
القول ان كل من هو ضد الرئيس هو ضد الدوله
كلا انهم ضد الرئيس لان هذا
الرئيس فعل كل يريد برايه الخاص وهناك خلط
بين الرئيس ود الدوله فقط فيما يتعلق
باسباب انتخابيه
اليوم منع الحديث عن هذه العمليه واللي هي
عمليه
ديمقراطيه وان الذين في السجون
يعتبرون
اليوم ويعاقبون المحاميان
الواقع اخت جوهر ب مبارك وليلى مصداق
واسلام
حمزه هذا هاتين المحاميتين الشابتين
حد الا قلي عن هذه العمليه ورغم ذلك
اعتقلت بطريقه تدع الى الفضيحه والمنظمات
الدوليه
ت يعني اشرك السيد السيد
محمد ذويب انت طبعا تشير الى ما ذكرته
السيده اسماء اخت السيد جوهر بن مبارك
عندما قالت انها احيلت للتحقيق فقط
لانها اعلمت الناس بمجريات هذهه القضيه
السييد محمد وويب السيد وا يقول ان ما
يحدث في تونس امر مخجل في الحقيقه و وطبعا
كما تعلم السيد سمير ديل واخرون يقولون
هذه تهم مختلقه وحتى الان لا يوجد اي ادله
والدليل ان هؤلاء يعني لم يحاكموا
وبالتالي هل هذا بالفعل امر مخجل
لتونس اهلا بك اولا السيد فرانسوا موقف
السيد فرانسوا لم يعد يعني تونس كثيرا
بطبيعه الحال قبل 25 جويني كانت تونس
تعنيه هذه المنظمات والجمعيات وموقف
الاتحاد الاوروبي وامريكا وغيره ولكن
السيد فرانسوا لم
يحين معلوماتي حول الوضع في تونس تونس لم
تعد دوله تحكمها يحكمها الاتحاد الاوروبي
او امريكا او تركيا او فرنسا او غيرها
تونس دوله مستقله تعالج الوضع كما تريد في
تونس حسب القوانين وحسب حقوق الانسان
والحريات وفرنسا بطبيعه الحال لا يمكن ان
تقدم لتونس فرنسا او امريكا او تركيا
وغيرها لا يمكن باي حال من الاحوال ان
يقدموا موقفا حول حقوق الانسان من تونس
واذكر السيد فرونسوا بالشاب بالطفل
الجزائري الذي قتل منذ اشهر وماذا يحدث في
في الاحياء التي يعيشها العرب والمسلمون
والافارقه من ممارسات عنصريه واحدثه حتى
عن الجليات الصفراء وم مارست فرنسا لذلك
هذا الامر لو تحدثنا
عنه نحدث عن يا سيد محمد د وليس لدينا
قرون لنتحدث عن ذلك يعني لدينا وقت قليل
وبالتالي دعنا نعود الى تونس وموضوع هذه
المحاكمات التي لا ادل عليها ولم يحاكم
المتهمون فيها وهل بالصدفه ان كل رموز
المعارضه في السجن او احيل الى التحقيق
يعني اليست الصوره
واضحه هو لو لو اوقف قوس القضاء التونسي
نعم القضاء التونسي لان قيس سعيد لا دخل
له في القضاء جماعه النهضه فقط لقلنا انه
ان ان قضيه مسيسه تم ايقاف بعض رجال
الاعمال على غرار كمال طيف الذي حكم
الدوله التونسيه ودولته منذ عقود ايضا تم
ايقاف مؤخرا عديد رجال اعمال من بينهم صهر
بن علي الذي اصبح حلف حركه النهضه بعد
2011 و واوقف السيد الدغري وغيره من
الفاسدين اذا القضايا ليست سياسيه بطبيعه
الحال
اذا الزمن القضائي الذي يتحدث عنه السيد
سمير ديلو الزمن القضائي كنا نطالب قبل 25
جيليا بالتعجيل به للسياسيين ولحقوق
وللنبي ولمع وحتى للنهضه انفسهم من اجل ان
يتم فض هذه المشاكل بسرعه ولكن السيد سمير
ديلو وحزبه الذين ابقوا ملف الجهاز السري
مثلا لمده 12 سنه بدون فتح فيه لا يمكن
الان باي حال من الاحوال ان يتحدثوا عن
الزمن القضائي والتسريع به في تونس لانهم
لو كانوا يريدون التسريع في زمن القضائي
لفض تلك المشاكل عندما كانوا يحكمون في
القضاء هذا اولا ثانيا اضراب الجوع الذي
دخل فيه سيد بن مبارك وسيد بن مبارك دخل
في اضراب جوع تقريبا منذ سنه في مدينه
المرار في مقر حزب تونس الاراده مع مع
والده ومجموعه اخرى من السياسيين ولكن اثر
ذلك لم لم تؤدي الى ذلك بطبيعه الحال ايضا
الزمن السياسي الذي اختير في توقيت اضراب
الجوع الان ليس بريء بالمره هو يتزامن مع
احاله ملف الجهاز السري الى الى القطب
القضائي لمق فحه الارهاب اذا القضيه
السياسيه نقطه اخرى لا يمكن باي حال من
الاحوال ان يمكن اعتماد شهاده لجان الدفاع
في كل العالم ابتدا من جاك فرجس ودفاع عن
اسبد موفيتش وانت قادم سيدي الكريم كل
لجان الدفاع في العالم تدافع عن
تبرئه منظورها فما بالك بالسيد سمير ديلو
الذي لو يتقدم القضاء اكثر انا لا اتهمه
ولكن سيؤدي الى قضايا اخرى قد تشمله وقد
تشمل قيادات حركه اذا الملف سياسي امتياز
الدوله التونسيه من حق ان تحل الملفات
ولكن الحديث على انه ملف سياسي هذا امر
فيه مغالط سييد سمير ديلو فييه مغالطه اذا
و وما جدوى الاضراب عن الطعام على هذا
النحو ولا يدل هذا على قله حيله المعارضه
في حقيقه
الامر اولا ما كنت استمعوا لو من تصريحات
على على لسان ضيفكم لا تستحقوا مجرد
التوقف عندها هي فقط عينه ليطلع الراي
العام الدولي على نوعيه خطاب المدافعين عن
هذه المنظومه التي تفتقد للمرءه قبل ان
تفتقد لحس احترام القانون فقط انا اقول ان
كما ي يعني سيد سيد سمير ديلوي سيد سمير
ديلو لو سمحت لا نريد يعني التوجه يعني
الى شخصنه الامور الرجل قال رايه وهو مرحب
به وانت تقول رايك اتوجه الى اي شخص انا
لا نريد التحدث عن نعم تفضل لا نريد ان
نتحدث عن لم اتوجه الى اي شخص انا تحدثت
عن المنظومه قلت ان هذه المنظومه هي
منظومه فاقده للمرءه وانا اؤكد على ذلك
ولم اشخص وانا احترم كل اشخاص ماما كانت
مواقفهم رغم ان ما كان يقوله ليس فيه ادنى
ذره من الاحترام فقط المثل التونسي يقول
ما معناه انه لا يدفع الى المر الا الذي
هو امر منه ما يدفع قياديين سياسيين الشيخ
ثمانين الشيخ راشد الغنوشي هو يشارف على
83 دخل في اضراب عن الطعام صبيحه اليوم
السيد جوهر مبارك هو استاذ قانون دستوري
ما يضطر هؤلاء الى خوض معركه الامعاء
الخاويه هو فقدانهم للثقه في منظومه اصبحت
تطبق اوامر السلطه التنفيذيه ضيفكم الكريم
تجرا على قول ان رئيس الجمهوريه لا يتدخل
في القضاء من الذي الغى استقلاليه القضاء
من الذي حلل المجلس الاعلى للقضاء من الذي
ظ الانصياع لاحكام المحكمه الاداريه التي
قضت بارجاع 49 قاضيا تم عزلهم ظلما
وعدوانا وبهتانا من الذي قال بان من
يبرئهم فهو شريك لهم من الذي اتهم هؤلاء
بانهم متامر وبان محكمه التاريخ قد قد
ادانتهم قبل القضاء ما الذي بقي لقاضي
التحقيق وما الذي بقي للدوائر الحكميه
التي ستنظر في ملف هؤلاء واي شجاعه
اسطوريه يجب ان يتح بها القضاه حتى يتحدوا
اراده السلطه التنفيذيه التي تملك عزلهم
متى شاءت اذا نحن في وضع لا يحتاج فيه
المسؤول السياسي الى رفع سماعه الهاتف حتى
يصدر امرا الى القاضي وانما المسؤول
السياسي خلق جوا من الرعب ومن الترهيب جعل
من القضاه مجرد وظيفه تماما كما ورد ذلك
في الدستور الذي كتب فرديا في 2022 سيد
فرانسوا ما جدوى تحركات كهذه التي تقوم
بها المعارضه مثل الاضراب عن الطعام في
رايك جي
ك اقول هذا الاضراب عن
الطعام في تحريك الموقف الدولي والهيئات
المدافعه اي اثر يمكن ان يكون لهذا لهذه
الاضرابات والتحركات الو مغز مع الاسف
عن الطعام هو الطري الوحي المتوفر لهلاء
سجناء السياسيين فهم بين ارب جدر التعبير
لتعبير عنه عن ارائهم ولجعل العالم
يتذكرهم ويتحدث عنهم لا يجدون غير هذه
الطريقه لحصول على نجده ومساعده وهذه ما
هو فضيحه في العالم هو ان اوروبا تغلق
اعينها ولا تريد الديمقراطيه في هذا البلد
العربي الديمقراطيه في
الواقع تؤتي بالاسلاميين
الاسلاميه النهضه الى السلطه لذلك فالرب
تريدك تضع حارس حارس يمنع ذلك فرنسا
واوروبا يريدون نظاما رئاسيا لا يبدون
حكومه ولا يرد تكك حكومه او برلمان ولا
يردون هناك عداله ولا يريدون فقط شخص واحد
يستطيع ان ان يفسد كل الامور حسب رغبته
الشخصيه وما حصل مؤخرا هو انه وزيرا
تونسيا يتحدث
الفرنسيه مع رئيس الشؤون الخارجيه
الروسيه كان يتحدث معه لانه في ذلك الوقت
المغرب والجزائر كان يحولان الخروج من
الفرنكوفونيه
هنا هناك اشخاص مسؤولين للشؤون الداخليه
يتحدثون باللغه الفرنسيه هذه رساله تبعث
لفرنسا للقول اذا كانت كان الاخرون مغادر
وه الفرنسيه فاننا نحن معكم وما
هوي الاخر هو يثير الدهشه هو ان ان
اليوم الرئيس قيس
عيد مزق مزق تونس لم تعد هناك عداله لم
تعد هناك دوله ولم يعد هناك اي سلطات
مركزيه ليبق سلطه واحده في البلاد هي سلطه
الرئاسه اليوم تعمل بصمت اسمحي سي سيد
محمد
ذويب سيد محمد ذويب يعني كيف نفهم
المفارقه في دعوه الرئيس الفرقاء للحوار
في دول مجاوره سالت فيها انهار من الدماء
ولا يحدث ذلك في تونس وكما قلت يعني كل
رموز المعارضه يا اما في السجن يا استدعوا
للتحقيق يا اما نكل بهم اليست تونس اولى
بهذا الحوار و وكما قلت قبل قليل يعني هل
هي الصدفه ان كل المعارضين يا في السجن
استدعوا للتحقيق اليست اعود واقول لك
اليست تونس يعني اجدر بالحوار الذي يدعو
اليه الرئيس
سعيد هناك عشرات المعارضين يعقدون الندوات
الصحفيه ويعارضون رئيس الجمهوريه في
البلاتوهات وفي الاذاعات دون ان اذكر
الاسماء بطبيعه الحال وقد قلت لك انه
بالاضافه الى معارضي الرئيس والذين حكموا
سابقا جميعا او
الذين انضموا الى جبهه الخلاص بعد 25
جويلي هناك رجال اعمال فاسدون اذا الحديث
حديث على ان الرئيس يضع معارضيه في السجن
هذا كلام بطبيعه الحال مردود على اصحابه
اتحدث بالضبط بالضبط نتحدث عن دعوات
الحوار يعني قلت لك يدعو متحاربين في دول
الجوار ولا يقوم هو بحوار المعارضين بل
يضعهم في
السجن الحوار لا يمكن ان يتكون مع
المتامرين على امن الدوله وم حكموا تونس
خلال العشر سنوات فسالت دماء الامنيين
والجنود وسفر الشباب وافلست البلاد وتحولت
الى العشريه التي تعرفونها بطبيعه الحال
الحوارات التي كانت تتم مثل اتفاق باريس
بين حركه النهضه ونداء تونس بعد ان يكون
يقولان في بعضهما ما قاله لم
يمره
سي تهم انت تتهم بالجمله ما دخل ما دخل
سيد غازي الشواشي او جوهر بن مبارك او
عصام الشابي ب بعمليات القتل والارهاب
التي تتحدث عنها ما دخلهم لا دخل لهم اصلا
لا يشار اليهم اصلا في هذه الملفات فلماذا
يوضعون في السجن او يتم التنكيل
بهم قضيتهم قضيه غازي الشواشي وجوهر
بنبارك وعصام الشابي ليست قضيه ليست قضايا
راشد الغنوشي بطبيعه الحال هم قضاياهم
التامر على امن الدوله القضايا تختلف من
شخص الى اخر حتى الذين تواجدوا في نفس
المنظومه حتى قيادات النهضه الموقوفه ل
ليست نفس القضايا بينها اذا والحوار نعود
الى الحوار تلك الحوارات التي كانت تقودها
فرنسا او حوار توسيع الحزام بين نبيل قروي
وحركه النهضه من اجل العفو على رجال
الاعمال وما الى ذلك هذا ذهب ولن يعود
تونس دخلت مرحله اخرى يجب ان يعيها العالم
بصفه عامه وخاصه ضيفك الفرنسي الذي مازال
يعيش على وضع ما قبل 1956 تونس اليوم
تفاوض الدول الاتحاد الاوروبي وغيره الند
للند وهذا هذا اهم نقطه لان الدول التي
تفتقد سيادتها الوطنيه
الضيف الس سيد نعم السيد فرنسوا دروش
حقوقي وليس يعني ليس له منصب
رسمي حتى يعني نحمله مسؤوليه سياسات رسميه
فرنسيه سيد سمير ديلو انت نفسك يعني
استدعيت للتحقيق كيف ترى افق هذه الازمه
في
تونس الافق هو اما الحوار الذي يرفضه
ضيفكم ويعتبر ان الصيغه الوحيده للحوار هي
الحوار الاحادي واما ان تتواصل الازمه
ويتواصل الخطاب السياد وي الشعبوي ومعه
التخوين والاتهام بالتامر تصوروا ان خطاب
التخوين والتامر قال حتى ضيفكم الكريم من
فرنسا وهنا بالمناسبه اوجه له التحيه
فالمجتمع الحقوقي هو عابر للحدود وعابر
للقارات وضيفكم الكريم هو
تونسي هوان وتونسي قناعه ما دام يدافع عن
صوره تونس وصوره تونس الحقيقيه ليست
الصوره التي تنتهك فيها الحريات وتداس
فيها الحقوق ولكنها تونس التي اشعت بعد
الثوره بدستور يضمن الحقوق والحريات رغم
كل المصاعب ورغم كل الاخطاء التي ارتكبت
ولكن لا بديل عن الحوار في كل تجارب
الدنيا في كل تجارب المقارنه المجتمعات
التي رفضت الحوار من مدينه رفراف في
محافظه بنزرت سمير ديلو عضو اللجنه
التنفيذيه لجبهه الخلاص الوطني وعضو هيئه
الدفاع عن المعتقلين ومن تونس الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي محمد ذويب ومن باريس
فرانسوا دوش رئيس جمعيه عداله وحقوق بلا
حدود شكرا جزيلا لكم جميعا وشكرا مشاهدينا
على المتابعه الى هنا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]
ا